all right Rosa yeah that's me okay
is this your family yes okay home
detection is all strategic Police
Department
uh what questions do you have from here
right now
um what's gonna go on like what can I be
with her can she's getting life pointed
out right now okay so they're taking her
right now okay I haven't spoke to her at
all
okay that's it so like what
like what's gonna go on like what what's
gonna happen with her like so she's
gonna get treatment before we even talk
to her because she needs to be
stabilized so that's why she didn't like
let it out okay once she gets stabilized
we'll try and talk to her
um the baby's gonna go up North for
autopsy more likely we'll be done with
him
the next day
um is she gonna get tanked after like
she released how get what like are y'all
gonna take her to custody or anything
like that that depends on what the da
finds we have to wait for the autops to
come back to see what happened
because
right now how everything happened
we
we're gonna do an investigation
get more information from all my officer
medical investigator up north and with
that we presented that to D.A see what
the D.A wants to do with charges if any
at all okay
okay so they already took her out no
she's getting like she's right now being
set up to go to sleep what do you mean
it should be pretty soon they make a
decision
because with the age of the dissident
they usually expedite autopsy reports
and such
with normal people that pass naturally
at home takes a couple months for us to
get reports back stuff like this we'll
get it back pretty soon
so
we don't know that's why he'll be going
up north
it has y'all's information been taken
yet
um you took my driver's license he took
her driver's license okay my phone
number her from no my phone number yeah
yeah so
even though she's of age if she's not
available
yes okay
just wanted to make sure so she
that's still her boyfriend
uh Mr boyfriend do you have a driver's
license
and is the address on you current on the
driver's license
because the terminal with all my does if
she's not if she's still in medical
then they do release the infant back
it'll have to be really somebody
that'll be up to all my who they
determine next to can is maybe the
parents but maybe you okay so that's why
we're gonna get everyone's information
I'm just going to run your name through
this question on how radio okay so I'm
just gonna call him
self 7 15. are you an APD
for the AG school can you run one OLN
out of New Mexico
it's 517.
should be
all right thank you sir appreciate it
thank you
as soon as they're done with it like if
everything's okay will I be able to
bring her home with me yes it will yes
okay it's I don't know where she'll be
going with me no my house I mean when
she gets like about it I don't know
which one they totally love this
Loveless yeah love us Regional yeah
that's my card keep a hold of me okay so
if she stays at Loveless and then she
gets released she can go back to y'all
okay
and we'll I'll be in touch with you to
try and stuff interview with her okay
okay would y'all mine
talk to me later when y'all are okay
yeah I was with her I know she talked to
him for a while on the phone
and then she came to me so I've been
with her the rest of the time today
so what did she come here for that she
told you
she had back pain
that's it that's it has she been having
back pain before yeah she's paying for
her and her hips is is no I mean she was
born with like her
I don't know it was like crooked her
sponge cake is my ex-husband he hit me
he beat me whenever I was pregnant with
her so she was early
so um
she had some problems with her hips like
I always had to take her to chiropractor
to get adjusted because she couldn't use
it like she was always getting
constipated like she had to get lined up
whatever so I mean I've been taking her
chiropractor
because I always thought you know well
this time
you know I didn't know I honestly didn't
know she was pregnant I didn't know
I just thought like she said I have back
pain more my hips are hurting me
I think I need to go to the chiropractor
I said okay let's go tomorrow but she
was like in really a lot of pain and you
know when did it start
like the pain yes
uh
today she's or yesterday she said it was
really bad that her hips were hurting
and her back
and then last night we're on the phone
together and she said her her hips were
hurting bad husband if anything else is
hurting and she said just everything
and she went to sleep but she's a
cheerleader too so
she's begging cheers they have cheer
competition she's
she works out I mean and she's been
acted this whole time she's been active
this whole time
and who does she live with me
she's in school she's a senior
so
and how long have you all been together
almost two years three years okay
so I'm not trying to be rude to you but
you are more than likely will would be
the father okay
no no
sometimes
um
so with everything that comes with that
uh
gets a little shaky when it's
newborn stuff like that but with like
this certificate stuff like that
interpreting his sons if you choose to
use them we'll be the ones to help you
get those
um
other than that because that's all
really you'd need
and they can help you with
the afterlife care okay
um
do y'all have any questions for me right
now
do you have my number you can that is my
work phone if you want to text me okay
or call me I have my email on there as
well okay
oh
sergeant and I got your information
right yes okay
let me give you my card too so you can
give me a call all right
just because I want to make sure
everyone stays updated okay
like I said I don't know there will be
charges that will be up to the District
Attorney's office
if any
or even done okay okay
it's too early in the game to know right
now so we're just gonna do the initial
investigation with I was on the phone
with our dispatch so all mines will be
here in 45 minutes it's one of their
field agents and they're the ones so in
state of Mexico we're not allowed to
touch anybody that's passed okay they're
called a decident they're the only ones
allowed to actually handle somebody
so we wait for them to even do anything
so hospitals allowed to do it because
they do care you know life-saving
records whenever life-saving effort
cease no one's allowed to touch them
so we have to wait for them to show up
before we even
start that side of stuff okay
so she's getting life-flighted out
we'll talk to her later okay you that's
if she even wants to talk to us she's a
student because she still has her
constitutional rights should I like
get a lawyer for her should I you can
that's your choice I can't tell you what
to do
that's something that y'all as a family
must talk about okay
over the Roswell yes
um she should be gone by now
so that's with the helicopters coming in
they want nobody near it so that way you
can't mess with anything because if any
of their vitals go off they'll stop it
which could be an issue for if they if
they need care immediately so that's why
whenever someone gets life flighted they
just cut off every like contact with the
family okay
because they're making sure she's
getting set up to get transported out so
that's why they tell you yeah it seems
very harsh but it's because with their
with the flight nurse the flight doctor
they have to make sure everything stays
constant okay
so she should be gone by now because she
was already getting prepped whenever I
came out to y'all okay
so with that like I said she'll be
leaving we'll stay here with Vanessa and
go from there okay okay
so once she gets to Loveless it's up to
level us if they'll let you back there
because she is of age so
um with covid and how everything goes it
just depends okay so if before you make
the join my call see if that's available
okay and just let them know what's going
on and we'll just let your family in
that it's possible okay all right okay
we'll be here if you need anything all
right I'll be over there and I'll just
Speedway all right okay
thank you so much all right folks
foreign